[Music]
[Music]
these are all absolutely real laws for
example in Idaho you could be common-law
married to no more than two potatoes at
a time in Portland Oregon you will be
fined for double parking your unicycle
unless it's for ukulele practice in
Maryland if Guy Fieri doesn't grunt
louder than 90 decibels when he tastes
your crab cakes you will be shot in Las
Vegas Nevada
each resident must serve a mandatory
four hours of community service as an
EDM DJ in Hollywood California if your
pilot gets picked up series you have 30
days to divorce your age-appropriate
wife in Queens New York it is always
legal to leave work if you need to see a
guy about a thing in Seattle Washington
it's mandatory to pledge allegiance to
one of the city's violent street gangs
Patagonia or North Face
in Abilene Texas is that a it is a
capital crime to promise Lurleen a
better life when you know plum well that
hardscrabble road don't lead to nothing
but pain baby love in Cleveland Ohio you
can be jailed for reminding anyone that
they are in Cleveland Ohio in Chico
California it's illegal to Bogart the
bong unless you're in the middle of
ranting about how Bernie would have won
in Des Moines Iowa it's illegal to be
interesting hey come on I'm from Des
Moines and I'm very interesting goodbye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in Green Bay Wisconsin it's illegal to
drive with a blood cheese content below
0.8 and finally in Lakeland Florida if
you get divorced your spouse is entitled
to 50% of your meth business
[Applause]
you